senior political officials of the Roman
state had to take auspices before any
major political event like elections and
before a battle they would draw on the
expertise of an augur from the College
of augurs membership of the College of
August was for life
with new members elected periodically
two of the main kinds of auspices that
were deliberately taken involved Birds
one type involved watching for the
flights of specific kinds of birds
eagles vultures buzzards or woodpeckers
or listening for the cries of birds
crows owls and eagles you had to work
out whether the birds were occurred or
bad and this was determined partially by
where they appeared in the sky in
relation to a grid that criss crossed
where the viewer stood the height at
which they flew and the speed and noise
of their wing movements the other main
method of bird divination involved
observing whether or not the sacred
chickens at the food that was given to
them you had to take auspices at night
and they were valid only for the day to
calm so if the activity you were taking
auspices for was continued or delayed
you had to repeat them even though you
were only looking for a yes or no on the
timing of the event the law was
complicated and open to interpretation
and to challenges even if the day had
been cleared for the activity other
officers of state could claim to see
spontaneous signs from the gods that
meant that the event had to be cancelled
you